Dubai is a work of
art take the three Palm Islands the
first one still isn't fully occupied the
second one is apparently abandoned the
third one is
cancelled the World Islands where no
sane person wants to live with all of
them sinking into the sea at a rate of 5
mm per year allegedly see those tanks
behind your multi-million dollar Villa
that is where your poop goes then the
poop ship shows up sucks out the
contents and takes it to a sewage
treatment plant because the World
Islands aren't connected to a sewage
system just like the world's stest
skyscraper which also relied on poop
trucks until recently but wellth thought
out engineering isn't the only thing
Dubai is famous for their style of urban
planning is also a work of Genius
spending billions of dollars on
demolishing an entire sea ecosystem to
build those islands to turn half their
surface into highways and parking lots
clever instead of the third Palm Island
building a bunch more smaller Islands
because the one thing Dubai lacks is
space to build obviously well at least
they used some of that space to build
golf oriented saltwater swamps next to
the Jungle of skyscrapers oh and there's
also this Industrial Area these massive
structures must be Logistics hubs
sandwiched between highways large
Vehicles parked all around them wait
what is this staff
accommodation oh oh all right I guess we
can call them staff now how
creative all right staff your job will
be to perform agricultural activities on
this rural cotton production compound
into this Vortex of foresight
intelligence and human rights comes Moon
World Resorts ink oh boy so the basic
idea of the project is to build a 30 m
tall cylindrical building and then on
top of it a 274 m Moon replica we have
the biggest brand in the world Henderson
told the Associated Press that's the
co-founder alluding to the Moon itself
the Heavenly Body was his brand 8
billion people know our brand and we
haven't even started yet that is not how
branding works okay inside the moon
structure there will be a skyscraper
with 4,000 hotel suites underneath the
globe in the massive cylinder shaped
building there will be three floors
containing pza okay also hotel lobby
Lounge restaurants boutiques Event
Center Concourse and other words they
found in professional literature wait
what's This Global meeting place oh
great finally I hate those meeting
places where people from other countries
aren't let in also why isn't the Global
meeting place inside the you know the
globe huge missed opportunity you might
have noticed that the large skyscraper
inside the globe housing 4,000 hotel
suites will have no windows whatsoever
love to spend my horribly expensive
vacation without ever seeing natural
light and what's the deal with that
empty space in the bottom half of the
sphere also Moon World Resorts Inc just
a hot tip before you try building a 300
M vity monstrosity please learn how to
use layers what is this the Contours
clip into the texture also this thin
Contour is missing on the two upper
floors plus you forgot to drag this
contour line to the end this is A5
billion project by the way the big
attraction of this project aside from
the whole giant Illuminating Moon thing
would be a lunar surface lunar Colony
inside the upper half of the sphere so
from the hotel you could take the
elevator I'm sorry I mean the shuttle to
the theme park and sure the idea does
sound interesting a little artificial
moonscape you can walk around in
experience your surroundings take a few
cool selfies sure the problem is the
project completely misunderstands why we
find the moon and photos of it so comp
in It's Dark Lonely far away from home
we can see the Earth in the distance but
will we ever make it back if anything
goes wrong this rock will be our grave
still the fact that we're here is a huge
step for Humanity we did The Impossible
we set foot on another Celestial body
for the first time how awesome is that
there's this terrifying Beauty this Aura
of danger edel Glory about setting foot
on the moon once you take all that away
however what else is there really not
much right it's just a flat gray Rock
Desert with nothing in it Mars is more
exciting than that and even there you
would be bored out of your mind after 10
minutes now take that flat empty Gray
Rock Desert and fill it with hundreds of
annoying tourists hordes of people just
kneeling around everyone is on their
phones children are screaming around you
people are trampling down the terrain it
would be the same experience as seeing
the Mona Lisa and oh boy is that a lot
of
fun so in the end this whole surface of
the Moon attraction would just boil down
to a gray dull landscape with fenced in
Pathways filled with hordes of tourists
the gimmick might be fun for the first
minutes but soon you'll be looking for
the nearest exit to escape from that
dark loud crowded room wreaking of X
body spray now you might be asking how
do I know that the moonscape will be so
boring and unpleasant well there aren't
any renders or illustrations of the
inside aside from some vague sketches
but these people aren't exactly
powerhouses of imagination you'll see
why in a moment illustrations of this
thing are just all over the place we
have these aforementioned weird sketches
that tell you nothing about the whole
construction there are these schematics
that look like they were made in Ms
paint or something otherwise there are
no plans there is no project summary no
additional renders or detailed
descriptions on their official Instagram
page we have a picture of some monal
train with moon written on it going in a
dark Forest under a full moon no
creatures on caged display no animal
cruelty no fur products 50% gender
equality at management and board level
complete gendering comparity 20% local
population Cre what the hell am I even
reading oh no what's this carbon
offsetting included within all revenue
streams a tree of Hope planted for every
guest equating to 10 million annually
plus every budding astronaut equating to
what this is the future this is Moon
comma mind plus body plus Soul plus
thoughtfulness plus generosity plus
kindness plus respect plus inclusiveness
plus equality plus meaningful and
Lasting change I'm sorry did they use
Chad GPT to write their well no
because Chad GPT knows how to punctuate
a sentence throughout their materials
there are serious issues with legibility
and grammar here take this other
illustration 25 elegant soaring Towers
housing an array of stunning luxury
residents singular not to mention the
Tilted second half of the sentence the
other similar promotional image I found
is just as bad 25 unique futuristic
sphere residence Towers comfortably
surrounding Moon Resort comma welcome to
living out of this world5 billion Resort
yeah bro we want to build like the 10th
wonder of the world or something in
Dubai we have that ambition we cannot
type out coherent English sentences yet
but we have the ambition so here's the
layat of this fever dream apparently the
moon will be in the middle surrounded by
a lagoon surrounding the Lagoon are 60 M
diameter sphere residential units so
these things around them are typical
Towers oh boy that's my favorite type of
tower 187 M stall 45 units and in front
of them are typical parking structures
so 11 story parking garages Each of
which having a pool and a park on top of
it and in front of those is the double
Road whatever that is which does not
seem to have any intersections outside
connections crosswalks or driveways and
these dark triangles in the corners are
denote service buildings well if you
think this is a joke speak for yourself
personally when I hear $5 billion luxury
Giga project this is the exact planning
quality I imagine but apparently there
are some other illustrations the private
Residence at Moon 500 Sky Villas
mysteriously embedded into Moon's lower
disk superstructure oh no there's a
third one welcome to the Tranquil
forested Lagoon oh no I'm about to Moon
myself if that's the Lagoon and those
are the typical Towers where are the
Spheres and the parking garages also
still no intersections outside
connections or driveways cool but how do
they have three separate plans on their
Instagram four actually because all
their renders just skip the lagoons
spheres and towers and plop it right in
the middle of Dubai these are the ones
everyone keeps sharing and they do look
decent despite all of them being in
random different locations within Dubai
but at this AP article oh hi Michael
there's also
this what am I even looking at is this
bad fan art now is credited to Michael
Henderson moonwell Resorts via AP oh God
they even forgot to erase part of this
low texture so it overlaps the wave
barriers o and that airplane oh God yeah
that's how contas work5 billion Resort
judging by the bad grammar the bad photo
shop the amateur visualizations the way
every post is written on the Facebook
page and the founders themselves this
looks suspiciously like a boomer Pet
Project a crazy idea one person has had
for years which they kept pitching to
investors but got nowhere because it's
obviously stupid I towards this
explanation since according to the
Wikipedia page Moon World Resorts was
founded in 2000 how then did the moon
World Resort suddenly become the
supposed next big thing in Dubai how do
you go from near complete obscurity to
getting invited to speak at the Arabian
travel Market convention in Dubai I
believe I have an explanation CA
consultant reached out to me a few
months back to talk about how Middle
Eastern fever dream Giga projects come
to be he was under the design end of
things so he usually had tasks passed
down to him from high above due to risk
of imprisonment or execution I cannot
share his identity but I've relistened
to our conversation and paraphrased what
he told me say the dictator wants a new
building which would be the Jewel of the
Middle East putting everything else to
shame so what he does is he takes a HTI
nepin in a pen and makes a quick doodle
that looks like total then he
conveys a really vague idea about it to
his team of handlers the team is then
timatic thrown into a panic because they
cannot ask him for clarification they
cannot ask what he's trying to
accomplish what are the overarching
goals Concepts and so on they cannot
have these conversations they just have
to make do with what they have the
handlers will then reach out to Des ERS
like myself and say okay listen we have
this sketch we're meeting the dictator
next week and he wants to see something
it has to be impressive we cannot bring
him anything rough or big and we cannot
ask for clarifications it's kind of like
appealing to a toddler we cannot do
anything practical we have to do Pizzaz
Bright Lights shiny colors and so on and
we have a couple of days to throw it
together crazy rich people have
extremely short attention spans when you
have a meeting with them you cannot have
several points of discussion such as
ethnographic or soil studies you cannot
talk about any of this you have 5
minutes within which you have to to sway
them with a pretty image so that's
reassuring based on all this
here's what I suspect happened the
emirati dictator looked at some other
megalomaniac project in a rival country
and thought look at that colossal dumb
building we will be different we'll
build something even bigger and Dumber
so he sketched out some vague and
the handlers had to present something in
response in their usual Panic they found
this Niche crazy project by Michael
Henderson and said yeah the boss would
like that so they reached out to Michael
who obviously accepted the offer on
Moon's Facebook page the first post is
from July 2019 fantasizing about a moon
Hotel in Las Vegas the next post is from
the 21st of September 2021 this time
with an actual render suddenly talking
about Dubai so outs say the handlers
contacted him shortly before then and
sent him some renders to work with a
week later he posted a bigger version
and just kept going posting more or less
on a monthly basis Moon Dubai is
reimagined on the Crescent tape of palm
jabel Ali oh no this really was just him
he got the professionally made renders
and decided to create a little Boomer Ms
paint edit of the image so yeah in an
interesting turn of events the moon
Resort fever dream likely got caught up
in another fever dream one of a middle
eastern dictator and then Global content
meals picked up the idea first around
September 2021 then in May 2023 and
started spamming it all over the
Internet seriously most of these
articles and videos are garbage my
favorite is this one from the slop
Factory called billion dooll builds
where a computer generated voice reads
out a script likely written by Chad GPT
under generic stock footage this Mega
project will emulate the conditions of
the actual Moon such as the low gravity
walking experience for guests to feel
what it's like walking on the moon as
tourism sales have skyrocketed in UAE
predictions indicate that high
performance is expected this winter when
neighboring katar usually these content
meals go crazy about projects that will
never happen in a million years the
Dubai moon Resort however despite being
painfully stupid unprofessional and
unimaginative might just become a
reality compared to monstrosities like
neom or deab it's relatively simple and
far more feasible only you know why well
because a dictator wants it apparently
and as we all know by now smooth brain
dictator plus construction project
equals a giant Moon textured
ball in the middle of a desert concrete
hellscape built and run by slave labor
so you know the usual and this was my
addition to the discourse surrounding
the Dubai moon Hotel thank you for
watching and if you enjoy my content
please consider supporting me on patreon
or here on YouTube by becoming a member
of the channel and I'll be seeing you
next
time